bonjour nicolas mirkovic merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur arte france
joe biden a fait part cette nuit de sa
grande préoccupation comment est ce que
vous êtes une aile à réaction du
président américain une fois de plus
c'est de l'hypocrisie totale de la part
des occidentaux des attentistes et de
washington n'oublions pas d'où viennent
à ces immigrés ils viennent du yémen ils
viennent de l'irak ils viennent de
l'afghanistan que des pays que l'otan ou
leurs alliés ou ses alliés ont tenté de
déstabiliser
donc si on veut regarder un problème
vous regardez à la source donc du coup
la source de ces problèmes c'est
l'ingérence de l'otan des atlantistes
dans ces pays là qui ont ils ont créé
ces crises ils ont détruit des pays y
ait cet afflux d'immigration et
aujourd'hui donc du coup on a cette
situation sur la sur la frontière entre
la biélorussie et la pologne mais
l'origine de ces crises et bien du côté
de l'otan et de des atlantistes après il
ya un deuxième volet cette hypocrisie
c'est que l'union européenne a décidé
d'ouvrir massivement ses frontières et
d'acquérir de libération du monde entier
c'est la stratégie de bruxelles il y a
officiellement plus quasiment 3 millions
d'immigrés qui rend dans l'union
européenne chaque année pourtant croire
union européenne richard sur la question
à tous les pays tous les membres de
lieux ne sont pas forcément d'accord
est exactement où notamment la pologne
notamment la pologne mais on est en
train de se focaliser sur ces quelques
milliers d'immigrés qui sont sur la
frontière qui sort d'une situation tout
à fait des détresses et de tension ça
c'est certain mais il ya le l'union
européenne ouvre massivement ses comptes
hier la pologne n'en veut pas la pologne
est le dindon de cette farce n'oublions
pas qu'il ya quelques jours encore le
parlement européen dix équipes à les
protéger le peuple polonais contre le
gouvernement polonais qui a une amende
quotidienne d'un million d'euros qui est
infligé à la pologne aujourd'hui parce
qu'elle veut rester souveraine et tout
d'un coup ursula von der leyen président
de la commission dit que la pologne doit
résister devenir la frontière l'union
européenne pour la protéger et c'est de
cette immigration importante alors que
l'union européenne elle-même a ouvert
les vannes et demande à cette
immigration massive donc du coup la
pologne entre eux entre de fela les
amants de la part de l'union européenne
et un mail en lui demande de faire face
aux bills ont réussi à papa saber aussi
parce que l'enjeu est là dedans c'est la
même les atlantistes veulent tensions
importantes sur la frontière de la
biélorussie parce qu'avec la biélorussie
vous avez la réussite ça le véritable
enjeu ce pas d'immigration soit les
quelques milliers d'immigrés qui sont là
sur counter polonaise c'est le fait
qu'il ait des tensions sur entre la
biélorussie et la russie et n'oublions
pas un point majeur qui a commencé sa
qui a commencé depuis l'été 2020 a
essayé de retourner la situation
politique en mai l'euro si l'union
européenne l'union européenne a
massivement et sa part des politiques
d'ingérence importante à financer des
militants qui ont essayé de renverser le
régime le gouvernement aura à minsk
aujourd'hui où était hébergé le
télégramme et une bonne partie des
opposants
comme des rats à minsk aujourd'hui en
pologne le réseau next à qui s'appelle
excès aujourd'hui et en pologne et on
sait qui est une activité importante de
la part des renseignements des services
polonais baltes contre la biélorussie ça
c'était en 2020 mais aujourd'hui la
guenon cible c'est clair et doit
certainement montrer que elle boit pas
elle va pas continuer à subir des
sanctions de l'union européenne à subir
de
sanctions alexandre loukachenko a dit
qu'il pouvait fermer les vannes de son
côté dmitri peskov le porte parole du
kremlin a tenu à rassurer hier en disant
que la russie continuerait à alimenter
en gaz l'union européenne qui croire
je pense qu'il va y avoir n'oublions pas
que la biélorussie et la russie sont en
train de former une union dont du coup
il y aura il y aura un dialogue entre
mais minsk et moscou je pense qu'il faut
on a plutôt tendance à ils peuvent
frapper tous les côtés je pense parce
que la femme et la biélorussie montrent
qu'elle ne veut plus se laisser faire au
mieux 5e ronde et sanctions de l'union
européenne contre la violence il avait
elle aussi au bout d'un an on dit je
n'avais plus subir je levais pendant
longtemps les attentistes petit pouvait
faire ce qu'il voulait dans le monde est
passé pouvait réagir là ils sont tombés
sur l'os il ya eu des exercices
militaires conjoints il ya entre la
russie et la biélorussie dans le secteur
à la frontière entre la pologne et la
biélorussie rien nouveau d'après moscou
contrairement à minsk
miss est tout ça à la crise actuelle
qu'est ce qu'il faut en penser
certainement c'est certainement plus
liée à la crise actuelle du mystère des
deux côtés vont montrer un peu leur
force on sait jamais je sais où ce genre
de crise peut déraper on espère que ça
vient
mais justement il peut y avoir un risque
d'embrasement parce que londres a envoyé
des troupes à également sur place
sachant que washington a des bases
militaires en pologne aux siens oui non
je pense pas qu'il y aura il y aura pas
de mouvement mais et militaires des deux
côtés ils veulent montrer leurs muscles
ça c'est certain ça c'est propre à
général a molesté d'aidé militaire ce
qui est intéressant c'est ce que vous
venez de dire pourquoi est-ce que la
pologne fait appel à d un militaire
britannique qui ne fait et ne vont plus
partie de l'union européenne ça c'est un
signal fort de cire que les polonais ne
font mais par apple alors voisins
européens pour les aider à les défendre
l'union européenne envoie pas de
militaires pour défendre la pologne la
pologne fait appel un pays qui en dehors
de l'union européenne c'est quand même
un signe c'est vrai c'est quelque chose
qui est extrêmement important la pologne
elle est tiraillée il est tiraillé ne
sait plus quoi faire elle ne veut pas de
l'immigration et l'a déjà dit mais
étaient sanctionnés par bruxelles pascal
appliquée ne voulait pas son quota à
d'immigrés aujourd'hui bruxelles se sert
de la pologne comme pion dans un jeu qui
est plus grand qui est contre la russie
et la biélorussie la pologne et la belle
dame en deux sets par la police afin de
se faire avoir elle ne sait plus quoi
faire et c'est pourquoi elle voudrait
plaire à bruxelles voudrait père
archipel mais on voit bien qu'il est
qu'elle est limité dans ses moyens
aujourd'hui merci nicolas mercredi
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes analyste
politique spécialiste des pays de
l'europe de l'est